c'est thomas l'audience et reprises je
vous rappelle que nous jugeons
aujourd'hui jean marie le pen qui est
inculpé de reconstitution de ligue
dissoute cas ils propagent des idées
stalinienne en prêchant pour le
totalitarisme
quel que soit ce totalitarisme et qui
est également inculpé de dilapidation de
fonds publics parce que les expulsions
d'immigrés qu'il préconise pour venir à
bout du chômage risque en fait de coûter
fort cher à ce pays
ces inculpations vont être répétée et
répercuté par l'organe puissant et
généreux du représentant de la société
le procureur général de la république
des proches française
[Musique]
françaises français belges belge
extrémistes extrémistes mon président
français de souche
mon émigrés préféré taione mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public chéri mon
amour comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
démontrer ici même récemment ramené mort
avec un brio qui m'étonne moi-même
malgré la haute estime en laquelle je me
tiens depuis que je sais qu'il coule
dans mes veines plus de 90% de ce vous
allez rire fait plus de 90% de sang à
rien et moins de programmes de
cholestérol les débats auxquels vous
assister quotidiennement mesdames et
messieurs ne sont pas ceux d'un vrai
tribunal
en réalité je le répète ceci est une
émission de radio à bizet qui puisait se
traduirait pas qu'ils puisaient une
émission de radio dite comique ou au
moins qu'ils tentent de l'être alors le
rire parlons-en et parlons-en
aujourd'hui alors que notre invité est
jean marie le pen
car la présence de monsieur le pen en
ces lieux vous est plus souvent à la
gaudriole par judiciaire pose problème
les questions qui me rend avec un alibi
les questions qui me ventes sont celles
ci premièrement peut-on rire de tout
deuxièmement peut-on rire avec tout le
monde
à la première question je répondrais oui
sans hésiter et je répondrai même oui
sans les avoir consultés pour mes
coreligionnaires en subversion
radiophonique luis rego et claude
villers s'il est vrai que l'humour est
la politesse du désespoir s'il est vrai
que le rire sacrilège blasphématoire que
les bigots de toutes les chapelles taxe
de vulgarité et de mauvais goût
s'il est vrai que ce rire là peut
parfois désacraliser la bêtise exorciser
les chagrins véritable et fustigé les
angoisses mortels alors oui à mon avis
on peut rire de tout on doit rire de
tout de la guerre de la misère et de la
mort au reste est ce qu'elle se gênent
la mort elle pour ce rire de nous est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle ne pratique pas
l'humour noir elle la mort regardons
s'agiter ces malheureux dans les usines
regardons gigoter ses hommes puissants
boursouflé de leur importance qui vivent
à cent à l'heure alors ils se battent
ils courent ils caracolent derrière leur
vie et tout d'un coup ça s'arrête sans
plus de raison que ça n'avait commencé
et le militant de base le pompeux pdg la
princesse d'opérette
l'enfant qui jouait à la marelle dans
les caniveaux de beyrouth toi aussi à
qui je pense est qui a cru en dieu
jusqu'au bout de ton cancer tous
tous nous sommes fauchés un jour par le
croche pied rigolard de la mort imbécile
et les droits de l'homme s'efface devant
les droits de l'asticot
bien alors je vous le demande mesdames
et messieurs les jurés
quel autre échappatoire que le rire
sinon le suicide poil en chine
donc on peut rire de tout y compris de
valeur - sacré comme par exemple le
grand amour que vit actuellement le
petit roy inamovible de l'incisive qui
ici présent son grand amour et qui
s'appelle marie cas c'est la seule à
rien au monde qui peut le supporter ce
qu on comprendra aisément quand on sera
qu'il s'agit de la poupée gonflable en
peau de morue se doit ce que ça t'a
rodriguez lui envoyer de lisbonne un
paquet cadeau coucher procu coucher
deuxième point peut-on écoute-moi luce
peut-on rire avec tout le monde
c'est dur personnellement il m'arrive de
renâclé à l'idée d'inciter mais igomatik
à la tétanisation crispé c'est
quelquefois au dessus de mes forces dans
certains environnements humain la
compagnie d'un stalinien pratiquant par
exemple me mets rarement en joie
près d'un terroriste hystérique je
pouffe à peine
et la présence à mes côtés d'un militant
d'extrême droite assombri couramment la
jovialité monacale de cette mine réjouie
dont je déplore en passant mesdames et
messieurs les jurés de vous imposer
quotidiennement la présence inopportune
au dessus de la robe austère de la
justice sous laquelle je ne vous raconte
pas attention ne vous méprenez pas sur
mes propos mesdames et messieurs les
jurés
je n'ai rien contre les racistes c'est
le contraire comme dirait mon charmante
amy le brigadier georges rabaul qui est
ici qui joue du piano ici tous les jours
et qui je le précise à l'attention des
auditeurs qui n'auraient pas la chance
d'avoir la couleur est presque aussi
[ __ ] que pianiste dans une zone dans
une journée particulière le film
d'ettore scola mastroianni poursuivi
jusque dans son sixième par les gros
bras mais souligne s'écrit
judicieusement à l'adresse du spadassins
qui l'accusent d'antifascistes vous
méprenez messieurs ce n'est pas les
locataires du 6e qui interagissent tu
sais les fascistes qui est il aux
catésiens les racistes sont des gens qui
se trompent de colère disait avec
mansuétude le président senghor qui est
moins pianiste mais plus [ __ ] que
j'entends
pour illustrer ce propos mais rabat les
français oui c'est toujours ça pour
illustrer pour illustrer ce propos je ne
résiste pas à l'envié de vous raconter
une histoire vraie monsieur le pen cela
nous changera des habitués à
l'élucubration néphropathique inhérentes
à ces regrettables réquisitoire c'est
une histoire de chauffeurs de taxi
justement je sortais récemment d'un
studio d'enregistrement c'est une
histoire vraie un j'assiste là dessus
sinon c'est pas intéressant
je sortais récemment d'un studio
d'enregistrement accompagné de la
pulpeuse comédienne valérie mairesse
avec qui j'aime beaucoup travailler non
pas pour de basses raisons sexuelle mais
parce qu'elle a des missions magnifique
nous grimpons dans un taxi m sens bien
nous soucier du chauffeur un monotone
quadragénaire de type romorantin
couperosé de frais et poursuivant une
conversation du plô d'intérêt culturel
tandis que le taxi nous conduit vers le
châtelet mais alors que rien ne le
laissait prévoir et sans que cela ait le
moindre rapport avec nos propos qui
n'écoutaient d'ailleurs pas cet homme
s'écrie soudain ah ben moi les arabes je
peux pas les sacs et ignorant ce trait
d'esprit sans appel ma camarade et moi
continuons notre débat pas longtemps
trente secondes plus tard sa part ben
moi les arabes vous comprenez c'est pas
des gens comme nous moi qui vous parle
j'en ai eu comme voisin de palier
pendant trois ans et ben merci bien ah
les [ __ ] alors leur musique à la con
merde
alors vous pourrez si vous voulez c'est
le père qui a des pistes et la fille
aînée
ah ça c'est comme ça c'est les arabes
alors ce coup ci je craque un peu je me
retourne et je dis monsieur je vous en
prie mon père est arabe
ah bon on marqué votre père je dis pas y
en a des instruits 1 et puis vous on
voit bien que vous est propre et tout
d'ailleurs je vous ai vu à bellemare à
l'arrière bringuebalé entre lire et la
joie nous voulons encore ignorées hélas
la pause est courte
oui votre père je dis pas mais alors les
miens d'arabes pardon alors ils avaient
des poulets vivants dans l'appartement
monsieur vous savez ce qu'il en est il
en arrachait les plumes rien que pour
rigoler et laka des chaussures que c'est
lui aussi qui l'épuisent les sachets sûr
ça s'entendait alors même et votre père
je dis pas et puis de toute façon les
arabes c'est comme les juifs ça
s'attrape que par la mer cette fois je
craque vraiment ma mère est arabe
monsieur à bonds à la concorde à stora
ya pas moyen
alors comment ces conneries mais sévère
mais il est con est de retour notre 117
déconneur vous voyez vous monsieur
reprend t-il à mon endroit un moment
derrière voulez vous que je vous dise
il n'y a pas que la race il y à
l'éducation c'est pour ça que votre père
et votre mère je dis pas d'ailleurs je
le dis parce que je le pense vous n'avez
pas une tête d'arabe et ça c'est croyez
moi c'est l'éducation remarquer
remarquez vous mettez un arabe à l'école
hop il joue du couteau et il empêche le
français de bosser ça bon alors voilà 67
rue de la verrerie nous y sommes
ça nous fait 32 francs je lui donne 32
for abba vous n'êtes pas généreux voleur
et le polish à c'est comme ça à me
venger enfin je ne donne pas de
pourboire aux blancs jamais
alors cet homme tandis que nous nous
éloignons vers notre sympathique destin
baisse sa vitre et me lance grave dans
quel sale [ __ ] à moi à moi qui fais ma
première communion à la madeleine voilà
voilà mesdames et messieurs les jurés
voilà un homme qui se trompait de colère
le temps qu'ils mettent un parti
socialiste mais pas nationale c'est
toujours ça de pris
le temps qu'ils mettent un parti ainsi
que la crainte de quitter mon nez rouge
pour sombrer dans la démonstration
politico-philosophique m'empêche de me
poser avec vous la question de savoir si
ce chauffeur de taxi était de la race
des bourreaux ou de la race des victimes
ou des deux ou plus simplement de la
race importuner qui partout foisonnent
celles dénoncées par georges brassens
des imbéciles heureux qui sont nés
quelque part quand sonne le tocsin sur
leur bonheur précaires contre les
étrangers tous plus ou moins barbare ils
sortent de leur trou pour mourir à la
guerre les imbéciles heureux qui sont
nés quelque part aussi bien les
serais-je maintenant la parole à mon ami
luis rego qui pousse à la guerre ici
même le plus troublant des cris des
larmes
luis rego a dit ici les chiffres sont
accablants
il ya de plus en plus d'étrangers dans
le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
etonnant non